young people across Europe can be hit
especially hard by the economic crisis
the 15 year old student already
wondering what to do when her school
life is over the 20-year old job seeker
with no qualifications but some valuable
work experience all the recently
graduated 26 year old desperately
looking for a first job whatever their
circumstances a lot of young people feel
frustrated fearful and hopeless is this
you aged between 15 and 30 and tired of
hitting brick walls in your efforts to
get a job then this clip is for you
whatever your background education or
experience gaining useful skills
additional qualifications all
participating vocational training can
really improve your employability want
to find out more then take a look the
europe-wide youth opportunities
initiative dedicated to helping you
build your working future feel the
relaxing essential skills then what
about an apprenticeship or a traineeship
there are many options for learning in a
vocational school or training center or
for learning on the job even a
combination of the two for why not try
the European voluntary service there are
lots of areas to inspire you sports
social care the arts and many more if
you're a student how about a placement
in a company in another European country
the Erasmus and Leonardo da Vinci
programs can help you find and fund this
opportunity so that afterwards you can
stand out to a potential employer back
in your own country want to start your
own business then look at the
europe-wide program Erasmus for
entrepreneurs that funds exchanges with
experienced entrepreneurs elsewhere in
Europe finally if you're keen to work in
an other EU member state your first uris
job could be perfect the scheme seeks to
match existing job vacancies with
suitable candidates in other European
countries it could even contribute cash
towards an interview trip or when you
move abroad oh one more thing to support
you further the youth opportunities
initiative also promotes across Europe
youth guarantee schemes that aim to
ensure young people are in a job
training further education within four
months of leaving school so there you
have it just some of the interesting
paths open to you we're not saying it
isn't tough but the job market in Europe
really does need to between now and 2020
baby boomers retiring these meals of job
openings are there for the taking
so don't give up being equipped and
flexible could just be the key to
smashing through that brick wall youth
opportunities initiative a springboard
to your working future